[Musica]
buon pomeriggio e buon pomeriggio a
tutti certo dopo la presentazione così
così giornalista vero presentarmi con
uno scolapasta togliamo la faccio una
che è meglio allora io sono qua per
parlarvi di imprenditoria di grande
imprenditoria globale mondiale e
transnazionale non farò una televendita
di pentole state tranquilli però questo
aggeggio e lo scolapasta ci servirà tra
pochissimi
intanto lo appoggio qua allora vi dicevo
imprenditoria globale transnazionale con
solide radici locali
se volete muovervi da un punto a a un
punto b nel mondo c'è l'azienda giusta
che fa per voi
questa azienda si occupa di viaggi è la
più grande agenzia di viaggi del mondo e
si occupa di voi soprattutto se voi non
avete diritto a entrare in europa per
esempio e quindi da kabul a vancouver da
smara fino a roma da damasco fino a
berlino e poi fino a goteborg c'è
un'azienda che farà per voi
e questa azienda si chiama la
trafficante incorporation qui ci sarebbe
una sigla però o trafficanti al siepi a
se volete
allora facciamo un esempio poniamo che
estate scappando da homs in siria perché
vi stanno cadendo le bombe sulla testa
abbiamo il pacchetto giusto per voi
avete pochi dollari in tasca non c'è
problema
il viaggio sarà un pochino lungo e un
pochino pericoloso però arriverete in
europa avete qualche soldino in più in
tasca e fuggite da una remota zona
rurale del ghana volete assolutamente
arrivare in puglia dove raccogliere i
pomodori 12 ore al giorno per cinque
dollari al giorno
abbiamo il pacchetto che fa per voi
attraversare del deserto vim barche rete
in libia e sarete in italia avete 10 20
30 mila euro a disposizione abbiamo il
pacchetto business class
arriverete in aereo con un passaporto
contraffatto abbiamo già provveduto a
oliare i meccanismi a corrompere le
guardie di frontiera e magari
l'ambasciatore o e console per farvi
rilasciare il visto questa azienda opera
un po in tutto il mondo ma io vorrei
occuparmi soprattutto del mediterraneo
allora dove sono i trafficanti e chi
sono i trafficanti non solo gli scafisti
ogni tanto il nostro ministero
dell'interno fa delle conferenze stampa
roboanti in cui dice abbiamo arrestato
al novecento scafisti se fosse una pièce
teatrale qualcuno di voi lì in fondo
dovrebbe dire e chissenefrega
se voi restate un piccolo spacciatore di
droga all'angolo della strada
cosa succede il giorno dopo ce ne è un
altro la stessa cosa accade con gli
scafisti
i signori delle frontiere i trafficanti
di uomini stanno al sicuro stanno nelle
retrovie sono manager in doppiopetto non
stanno lì sui barconi stanno ad addis
abeba stanno istanbul stanno islamabad
stanno a bamako e hanno business magari
irregolari di copertura o che affiancano
al business criminale possono avere
compagnie marittime di navigazione
possono avere flotte di pescherecci
agenzie di viaggi a tutti gli effetti
possono essere poliziotti i signori
delle frontiere operano non in front
line non si sporcano le mani fanno
sporcare le mani agli scafisti che sono
i pesci piccoli
sapete chi è lui no lui è stato il primo
scafista della storia allora
questa cosa un po enti e blasfema non
l'ho detta io è la detta alexander che è
uno scafista siberiano che ho incontrato
in carcere alcuni anni fa
alexander da dietro le sbarre mi ha
guardato negli occhi e mi ha detto non
li fermerete mai non fermerete ma i
migranti non fermerete mai trafficanti e
sapete perché perché mosè è stato il
primo scapito della storia e io sono
come mosè boom alexander scafista
siberiano diplomato alla scuola di vela
di vladivostok appunto in siberia
lavorava per un trafficante di nome
muammar kousuke marco ciò che è un
grande imprenditore del crimine è un
talento è un genio ha tirato fuori dal
coniglio un cilindro pazzesco e il
contrario scusate dal cilindro un
coniglio pazzesco
quella sarebbe stata una vera magia e
peraltro allora avete presente i vecchi
barconi della speranza ai pescherecci
sgarrupati quei gommoni che vediamo
partire dalla libia che non riescono a
reggere nemmeno un paio di ondate
dimenticateli ma marco ciuc si è
inventato gli yacht di lusso yacht di
lusso di cui il mar egeo da marzo a
ottobre e pieno dalla costa anatolica
fino in grecia e poi giù fino al salento
pieno di turisti no chi è che non ci ho
mai pensato una volta e fare una vacanza
in barca a vela
ecco anche lui ci ha pensato un bel
giorno di una mattina di primavera di
qualche anno fa
alexander sta guidando uno yacht come
questa un bellissimo cappellino da
skipper una rassicurante bandiera o
greca o turca insomma niente di sospetto
ma viene fermato dal guardacoste leccese
perché perché lo yacht era un filino
basso sulla linea di galleggiamento
allora lo fermano gli dicono a documenti
e documenti tutta post settimana
chi c'è sotto coperta dalle grappe
milioni di turisti americani in vacanza
apri apre 40 afghani 40 afghani che
venivano da herat 40 afghani col mal di
mare ovviamente nasce in montagna fai
due settimane di crociera nell'egeo e
ovvio ognuno di questi afghani aveva
pagato 10 mila euro a testa
quel vascello valeva 400 mila euro
un'operazione geniale mentre tutti
pensavano i barconi della speranza lui
si inventa la cosa più mimetica
possibile ma omar cook di barche come
questa ne andate e decine a centinaia
prima che le leccesi scoprissero questo
questo trucco questo inganno ma marcus
che ha fatto un sacco di soldi milioni e
milioni di euro ha reinvestito pare
parte dei proventi comprandosi 200 ville
sulla costa anatolica e poi sotto
prestanome si dice abbia comprato
un'azienda farmaceutica
i maligni dicono che così produce
pillole contro i mal di mare dai gli
afghani allora fa un sacco di soldi e
questa è un'azienda che fa un sacco di
soldi
diamo un po di numeri io amo dare i
numeri detta così sembra un po però
insomma allora ii venne hcr sono
arrivati l'anno scorso via mare 360
2.753 migranti
ho fatto una piccola stima ribasso
ognuno di loro ha pagato tremila euro il
costo del viaggio
fate i conti 1 miliardo di euro
fatturati illegamente nel mediterraneo
un miliardo di euro cash che non
possiamo tracciare che finiscono anche
ad alimentare altri business come droga
armi e forse anche terrorismo non lo
sappiamo non sono tracciabili quindi
tutto è ipotizzabile
però ho fatto una stima ribasso perché
pensate che arriva dai luoghi più
lontani questa è solo l'ultima tratta
chi arriva da kabul e ha dovuto
attraversare a piedi le montagne del
dell'iran e poi della turchia ha dovuto
pagare i vari trafficanti questo
mediterraneo vale miliardi di euro ogni
anno
io vi sto raccontando il secondo
business al mondo dopo la droga si dice
nel mondo 10 miliardi di euro di
fatturato
ogni anno con una piccola differenza
rispetto alla droga
poniamo che io stia portando un carico
di cocaina attraverso il sahel e lo devo
consegnare a mokhtar belmokhtar sapete
chi è mokhtar belmokhtar è un tipino ex
leader di al qaeda nel maghreb islamico
detto mister marlboro man per che
traffica in sigarette detto il guercio
ha perso un occhio combattendo in
afghanistan è l'ultima persona al mondo
con cui vorrei contrarre un debito è
l'ultima persona al mondo a cui io
dovrei consegnare il carico di cocaina
che poi ho perso nel cell
vi immaginate rischio altissimo invece
io perdo un camion di migranti nel sahel
con 180 persone che hanno già pagato il
viaggio la vocina al in fondo mi dirà
chi se ne frega è un business a rischio
zero
la trafficanti corporation funziona
anche per questo ma per altre
caratteristiche veleni con molto molto
brevemente primo gli attori i
trafficanti si parlano tra di loro
correva l'anno 2013 ero al cairo a
piazza tahrir con ancora gli echi di
quella rivoluzione l'abbiamo chiamata
primavera araba diciamo un lungo autunno
e incontro eldo ii ed oli è un
trafficante aldo lì la prima domanda che
mi faccio è senti ma chi è il boss dei
boss che è il più grande trafficante nel
vostro campo lui mi guarda dritto negli
occhi e mi dice se mi fai questa domanda
non hai capito niente e ho detto beh è
un bel modo per iniziare un intervista
no siamo tanti ci aiutiamo ci facciamo
favori collaboriamo tra noi ci prestiamo
i soldi io lavoro con i libici per
esempio ma anche con i sudanesi allora i
trafficanti si parlano si aiutano non
esistono frontiere barriere anzi
lavorano su quello sono flessibili e
veloci
l'europa chiude una rotta e loro ne
aprono subito un'altra
l'europa afferma e barconi e loro si
inventano yacht di lusso e offrono
servizi su misura
l'agenzia di viaggi il legale del mondo
ti offre il pacchetto su misura
scusate si parlano comunicazione
cooperazione e servizi su misura
flessibilità sono tutte le
caratteristiche che l'europa non mette
in campo c'è l'europa che vuole
fronteggiare il traffico dei migranti e
vuole gestire il dossier immigrazione
non mette in campo quello che il crimine
mette in campo
e incredibile la trafficanti corporation
non è solo questo e anche social e come
ogni azienda che funziona a un
dipartimento marketing efficientissimo e
ai social media manager quindi usano
facebook
instagram viber è telegram non ci
credete
ecco qua profilo instagram di un
trafficante
ecco il sogno europeo facebook
profili facebook aperti dove trovate le
tariffe per esempio da dove si parte in
quanto tempo si arriverà in europa i
bambini sotto i 12 anni viaggiano gratis
soddisfatti o rimborsati
non sto scherzando è così offrono
pacchetti su misura con delle promozioni
marketing quel tipo i 3x2 del
supermercato sono social
se noi avessimo monitorato attentamente
i social media social network
a fine dicembre del 2014 avremo capito
che qualcosa di molto grosso stava
bollendo in pentola
questo il 31 dicembre del 2014 è una
notte buia e tempestosa è vero erano
l'attribuire tempestosa e mentre a lecce
tutti si preparano per il capodanno
questa nave o meglio un'altra nave molto
simile blue sky sta veleggiando e punta
dritto verso santa maria di leuca non
risponde alle segnalazioni non risponde
alle richieste da parte della
capitaneria di porto
tira dritto scatta l'allarme terrorismo
kamikaze partono si levano in volo gli
elicotteri della marina militare uomini
dei corpi speciali si calano a bordo
irrompono in cabina e cosa trovano
terroristi
no esplosivo no 768 siriani 768 siriani
era l'inizio della più grande e geniale
operazione di traffico di migranti della
storia recente
a parte quella di mosè e appunto in due
mesi
17 cargo come questi sono arrivati sulle
coste del sud italia
cinquemila migranti trasportati quasi
tutti i siriani quindi richiedenti asilo
8 mila euro il costo medio del biglietto
un fatturato di 40 milioni di euro
mica male tutti con cargo a fine vita
cardine utilizzabili e non ferraglia
questa è imprenditoria criminale geniale
e talentuosa a questo punto sorge
spontanea una domanda chi è il più
grande alleato dei trafficanti di uomini
noi noi e lo scolapasta e finalmente
e adesso grande televendita 3x2 le pen
no allora quanti buchi riusciti a
tappare con due mani 10 non di più ecco
questa è l'immigrazione ci sono molti
più buchi qua per quanto noi proviamo a
tamponare a chiudono una rotta a
chiudere una porta si aprano finestre si
squarceranno muri non ce la possiamo
fare il nostro appoggio è totalmente
sbagliato noi siamo il più grande
alleato dei trafficanti noi che
costruiamo i muri sapete perché i muri
alimenta nel business dei trafficanti
perché come diceva alexander non li
possiamo fermare noi costruiamo il muro
la rotta si allunga più trafficanti
coinvolti viaggio più pericoloso più
soldi che vanno alimentare il business
criminale
la parola chiave è vuoto l'europa non
c'è l'europa non dà una risposta legale
alternativa al siriano che è costretto a
spendere 10 mila euro per esercitare un
diritto riconosciuto dalla legge
internazionale e dalla legge italiana si
chiama diritto d'asilo non c'è una
risposta istituzionale c'è un vuoto
riempito dal crimine in questo
comportamento l'europa è decisamente
colpevole perché lui ng erano davanti al
mare libico perché non c'era l'europa la
parola chiave quindi è vuoto ci sono
però delle soluzioni bio bio un po
depressi si no le soluzioni ci sono
attenzione allora innanzitutto tagliamo
alle gambe al business dei trafficanti
proponiamo delle soluzioni legali per
esempio con i corridoi umanitari che ci
sono ma sono residuali stiamo parlando
di centinaia migliaia di persone sono
pochissime aiuti investimento per lo
sviluppo nei paesi di origine dobbiamo
rendere non conveniente partire dal
ghana non andare investire in libia e in
niger come l'italia e l'europa sta
facendo quelli sono paesi di transito
quello che stiamo facendo noi a chiudere
le rotte tra un po si riapriranno io mi
ci gioco la camicia ci troviamo qua fra
un'ora fra un anno se mi invitate ancora
si sarà riaperta la rotta turca perché
stiamo pagando per chiudere i buchi di
quello scolapasta non funziona
cooperazione di giustizia internazionale
inutile che restiamo i pesci piccoli gli
sfigati che sono gli scafisti dobbiamo
restare i boss dei boss che sono al
sicuro
quindi un volenteroso magistrato di
palermo deve poter parlare con un
magistrato libico è difficilissimo
monitoraggio dei social internet è una
fonte pazzesca di informazioni quindi
dobbiamo stare molto molto attenti
armonizzare le norme sull'immigrazione
in europa l'europa fa un po quello che
gli pare la germania accoglie milione di
siriani l'ungheria fa un muro
la francia cile respinge l'italia non sa
bene cosa fare tutto questo crea
opportunità per la criminalità
anche questo deve essere evitato
l'effettiva riallocazione dei migranti
in tutta europa
e adesso ci arriviamo meglio e vorrei
chiudere con un paio di inviti il primo
invito e alla categoria di cui ahimè
faccio parte i giornalisti i giornalisti
hanno raccontato e continua a raccontare
l'immigrazione con due parole invasione
emergenza non è né l'una né l'altra non
è emergenza perché l'immigrazione
strutturale un terremoto è un'emergenza
lo scoppio di una guerra è un'emergenza
l'invasione
scusate lapsus freudiano l'immigrazione
esiste da vent'anni gli sbarchi esistono
da vent'anni e come diceva alexander
continueranno quindi prendiamo la
comandato strutturale invasione 362 mila
arrivi su 500 milioni di abitanti in
europa è un'invasione
e come se adesso fatte salve le
proporzioni entrasse un gomito e mezza
caviglia di un siriano e voi
l'invasione siriana no non è
un'invasione chiamiamo le cose col loro
nome
quindi cari giornalisti stiamo ai fatti
e poi c'è un invito alla politica
cara politica non strumentalizzare
quelle cose lì perché si vota tra 6 mesi
e parla alla pancia e fai paura la gente
se il giornalismo restituisce la dignità
dei fatti la politica non li può
strumentalizzare e la politica mentre il
giornalista deve raccontare i fatti o
dalla politica voglio visione che in
italia che europa vogliamo fra dieci o
vent'anni questo vorrei poi però c'è un
invito anche per voi col
sull'immigrazione come su tante altre
cose
noi tutti abbiamo il diritto ad avere
un'opinione abbiamo il dovere di avere
un'opinione informata esigete cercate
informazioni di qualità che c'è
esige tela il giornale i giornalisti il
giornalismo
noi dovremmo essere i cani da guardia no
io spesso troppo spesso vedo dei
simpatici barboncini dei teneri bassotti
che ti portano la ciabatta del chihuahua
un po urla chianti ecco per favore
esigete dei solidi rabbiosi guardinghi
cane lupo e in bocca al lupo grazie